but yeah dude that was a that was a
mind-bending podcast he is
in he's he does his research he's really
smart i've listened to
hours and hours and hours of that guy
talk i'm definitely going to watch his
podcast that it's a good one i bet
everything he says is just so we talked
about it takes you on a deep journey
into the history of mankind you know
like he believes that humans have
existed for
long long before what the history books
say you know
super interesting guy we talked about
atlantis this lost city of atlantis and
where he thinks it is yeah and he's
going up there to uh to do some filming
and to go in a submarine
around uh the azores
to try to find atlantis you know where
the azores like the azores plateau it's
like if you go up to spain
and you go directly out into the middle
of the atlantic it's like halfway it's
like almost halfway between uh greenland
and spain
and uh that's where he thinks atlantis
is and he's gonna go into a submarine
and explore underwater that's where the
azores is that's where he thinks the
lost city of atlantis was that looks
like somewhere that atlantis would be um
so there's some there's some submerged
volcanoes and mountains right there
interesting and there's some crazy
looking [ __ ] pull up some photos of the
azores on like google photo or whatever
this would be an epic trip
for the joke squad
i think there's surf there too there's
that's where they film the beach there's
good surf there it does look like the
beach right get rid of island maybe
oh man
yeah it's just azores yeah
yeah there's some insane
[ __ ] in the air that'd be so cool i hope
he discovers something that's like
groundbreaking so sick it's his it's
been like his life's work you know
yeah there's rare it's rare you find
somebody who's dedicated that much of
their life to one specific thing geology
yeah he's been on
rogan's podcast three times too i'm
pretty sure i think it's like seven
times is it yeah oh [ __ ] but he's like
so into
geography and cosmology like somebody
who knows so much about the history of
the earth and rocks and then so much
about the [ __ ] stars and the planets
and he's got it all on paper too he's
awesome
he compiles like
so many other people's research you know
yeah everything like collects all their
thoughts and
all their facts and everything that
they've learned and yeah he paints some
really cool pictures you guys watch the
uh youtube channel after school
it's spelled with a k it's one of my
favorite channels that exists on youtube
and it's just a guy who's really good at
drawing
and
he takes
philosophers and politicians and
comedians and influencers and takes like
passages of things that they've said
mostly philosophers and he draws
pictures to what they're saying
yeah if you click on any one of his
videos yeah like the last video he made
was eight days ago terence mckenna i try
to watch so say one you know i made like
a daily goal to watch one of this guy's
videos a day because he's just takes so
many
different wise people's
words
and uh
makes really cool videos okay he does
these super fast animated videos yep
he's really awesome channel though
because i mean i feel like everything is
very like
inspired like enlightened yeah
awesome turn the air on
so yeah 10 10 recommend this channel if
you haven't checked it out
check out his large library videos and
find something you like and
check it out
you guys are familiar with like the
fibonacci sequence then like because um
randall carlson is a big
i mean he works with gran graham hancock
pretty closely and uh graham hancock
released the book uh fingerprints of the
gods
you guys looked into that stuff yeah i
read fingerprints of the gods yeah yeah
fibonacci is crazy just explain it to
people
um
it's just a series of numbers just like
one plus two is three two plus three is
five so on and so forth and then if you
take like a one by one box and you put
it next to a one by two box and you put
an extra 2x3 box yeah it creates the
perfect spiral that's been
seen throughout all of nature waves
shells your eye
you know it's just it's uh
it's undeniable throughout the entire
universe and if you like count the count
the amount of spirals on a pine cone or
on a flower on a tree
they'll like pretty much always add up
to one of the fibonacci sequences
like uh there's this other youtube
channel this girl and she takes all
kinds of
fruits and
vegetables and plants and flowers and
pine cones and she draws on all of the
spirals and counts all of them and they
just always add up to be a fibonacci
number really yeah what does he equate
that to like what does he weigh that to
like they just call it like the they
call it like the fingerprint of the gods
it's just something that
can't be explained yet it's everywhere
you know
is it at all tied into the anunnaki i
don't know what that is
dude randall's a wild [ __ ] guy
randall is a beast he knows some [ __ ]
like some of the [ __ ] that he told me
like about the moon
and like
about how
the moon could possibly be hollow
have you ever heard the story about how
they ran a satellite oh yeah and they
like reverberated for like 60 hours or
something crazy yes i did hear about
that
yeah it rung like a bell yeah
i forgot about that there's so much
crazy [ __ ]
and he was saying you know one of the
things i asked him about when he was on
here
i was like i was like so if you were
in charge of like
our species on earth
i'm like what and you knowing everything
that you know because no one can
possibly know what you know
randall
what would you do right now like what
what should we be doing right now he's
like
the number one priority for us right now
should be to preserve our species
is to
get
us onto the moon like get us living on
the moon as soon as possible
i'm like not mars or anything he's like
no he's like mars is gonna take too long
there's all these problems elon thinks
that mars is in the near future
yeah elon says it's gonna be how long
does he say it's gonna be like 50 100
years yeah i mean i thought it was even
less than that but he seems very
confident in his rockets abilities and
oh man but the moon is going to have to
be an intermediary point to the mars
so he's like the first thing we should
do is get on the [ __ ] moon because if
something happens on earth we need a way
to at least get some of us off the earth
to preserve our species because he he
truly believes that there's an
extinction level extinction event coming
very soon wow
and we're in that 100 year window right
now yes
for not only the asteroids but the super
volcanoes would you go to would you go
to the moon if everybody started moving
there [ __ ] i mean what kind of life is
that you know
what i'll probably just catch the wave
that the last ride tsunami yeah i'll
just go away
there's no surf on the moon yeah no he's
talking an event though that would be
like
like
like every everything ends like a shock
wave so powerful that like you just die
instantly yeah well yeah not only i mean
instantly like
it depends how close you are to like
they're saying it they're saying if the
i think i watched the yellowstone
documentary they said the volcano
erupted
it would be it would be
everyone in the u.s would die
within a couple weeks
obviously in like the two like the 500
mile vicinity of the volcano instant
death
but um the entire united states would
take a couple weeks and then it would
eventually get over to europe and we
would run out of oxygen right yeah and
it would black out the skies [ __ ] would
die
and everything would have to rebuild oh
my god dude could you imagine like just
like
when hurricanes come here and we lose
power for a week or two like irma
remember irma
yeah dude i feel like that that volcano
the last one that erupted in the ocean
like that was a real wake-up call
life as we know it can change like that
like everything you know like all
and that's another problem that i have
with like grinding tick tock and like
putting all my time into
something that doesn't like serve me or
the planet you know i want to do stuff
that i enjoy
like i feel like our days are numbered
obviously they are numbered but
i